what's up ladies and gentlemen how are
we all doing today before we get started
I just want to say happy Mother's Day to
all the wonderful woman out there that
are watching and listening to this I
didn't release a video yesterday so I
didn't get a chance to tell you that but
I just wanted to let you know on behalf
of all of us men out here that we
appreciate you and it's been a while
since I made a breaking news or update
video about Game of Thrones so today I
want to do that because there is some
very exciting news within our community
right now I'm sure most of you know by
now HBO is in the developmental stages
of creating another television series
based off this incredible fantasy world
that george RR martin has created the
news broke about a week ago that stated
HBO was in the process of developing for
different spin-offs based within the
world of A Song of Ice and Fire which is
great news because I think I can speak
for all of us when I say we do not want
this to end we might want closure with
Game of Thrones but I know most of us
would love to have more assuming it's
done right and luckily for us it looks
like that's exactly what's going to
happen and we actually got a
confirmation from the man himself george
RR martin yesterday George posted an
update on his not a blog and I will put
the link down in the description just in
case you would like to go and check that
out but I want to read to you exactly
what George said so I don't misquote him
I think you will find some of this to be
very interesting and exciting as I did
George said so while I was on the road
out californee away the story broke
about the for Game of Thrones spin-offs
that HBO is developing and of course the
news has since spread everywhere all
over the web and all over the world yes
it's true more or less though as is all
too common these days
various distortions and misapprehensions
have crept into some of the reports
along the way in television being the
fast-moving business that it is there
have already been some further
developments for what it's worth I don't
especially like the term spin-off and I
don't think it really applies to these
new projects what we're talking about
our new story said in the secondary
universe to borrow from Tolkien's term
of Westeros in the world beyond the
world I created for a Song of Ice and
Fire
it is a world in a pretty big one and if
there were eight million stories in The
Naked City back in the 50s just think
how many more there are in an entire
world in one with thousands of years of
recorded history
none of these new shows will be spinning
off from Game of Thrones in the
traditional sense we are not talking
Joey or after match or even Frasier or
Lou grant where characters from one show
continue one to another so all of you
who are hoping for the further
adventures of Hawkeye are doomed to
disappointment every one of the concepts
under discussion is a prequel rather
than a sequel some may not even be set
on Westeros rather than a spin-off or
prequel however I prefer the term
successor show that's what I've been
calling them yes I am involved and has
been for months I had my first meeting
with HBO about the possibility of a
successor show back in August when I
pitched them two possible series one of
those is among the concepts being
developed and one is not in the months
that followed other writers were brought
in and pitched other ideas ultimately
HBO decided to go ahead with four
separate developments to be written by
Max Borenstein Jane Goldman Brian
Helgeland in Carly Rae and I apologize
if I mispronounced any of those names it
is stated in some of the reports that I
am working with two of the four writers
that's not quite right I've actually
been working with all four of the
writers every one of the four has
visited me here in Santa Fe some of them
more than once and we've spent days
together discussing their ideas the
history of Westeros and the world beyond
in sundry details found only in the
world of Ice and Fire in the lands of
Ice and Fire they are all amazing
talents and I am excited to be working
with them in between visits I've been in
touch with them by phone text and email
and I expect there will be a lot more
back and forth as we move forward and
there's more we had four scripts and
development when I arrived in LA last
week but by the time I left we had five
we had added a fifth writer to the
original four no I will not reveal the
name here HBO announced the names of the
first four and will no doubt announce
the fifth as well once his deal has been
closed he's a really terrific addition
however a great guy in a fine writer and
aside from me and maybe a Leo and Linda
I don't know anyone who knows and loves
Westeros as well as he does some of the
reports of these developments seem to
suggest that HBO might be adding four
successor shows to the scheduled to
replace Game of Thrones
decades of experience in the television
and film have taught me that nothing is
ever really certain but I do think it's
very unlikely that we'll be getting four
or five series at least not immediately
what we do have here is an order for
four now five pilot scripts how many
pilots will be filmed and how many
series might come out of that remains to
be seen if we do get five series on the
air I might have to change my name to
dick direwolf the one goal that everyone
involved shared here is to make these
new shows just as good as Game of
Thrones itself not an easy task mind you
David Benioff and Dan Weiss or a tough
tough act to follow as all those Emmys
demonstrate I can't tell you what the
shows will be about well I could but I
won't but I will tell you a couple of
the things they won't be which will
disappoint some of you sure but better
to do that now than later I think we're
not doing Dunkin egg eventually sure I'd
love that
and so with many of you but I've only
written and published three novellas
today and there are at least seven or
eight or ten more I want to write we all
know how slow I am and how fast the
television show can move I don't want to
repeat what happened with Game of
Thrones itself where the show gets ahead
of the books when the day comes that I
finish telling all my tales of Dunkin
egg then we'll do a TV show about them
but that day is still a long way off and
also we're not doing Robert's rebellion
either I know thousands of you want that
I know there's a petition but by the
time I finish writing a song of ice and
fire you will know every important thing
that happened in Robert's rebellion
there would be no surprises or
revelations left in the show just acting
out of conflicts whose resolutions you
already know that's not a story I want
to tell just now it would feel too much
like a twice told tale more than that I
will not say feel free to make your
guesses if you like but I'm not going to
be confirming or denying anything so
don't expect replies and yes before
someone asks I'm still working on ones
of winter and we'll continue working on
it until it's done I will confess I do
wish I could clone myself or find a way
to squeeze more hours into the day or a
way to go without sleep but this is what
it is so I keep on juggling winds of
winter five successful shows fire and
blood for new wild cards books some
things I can't tell you about yet but
it's a good thing I love my work
okay Wow now I know that's a lot to take
in but I'm really happy George took the
time to give us these details and set
the record straight now let's go over a
few of these things first things first
George said none of these new television
shows that are in development will be a
quote-unquote spinoff series which means
we will not get any continuation of any
of these characters from the game of
Thrones series nor will we get anything
immediately leading up to the Game of
Thrones series so basically whatever new
show we get it will be completely all
new characters which i think is a good
thing because just like he said he
doesn't want to create another show that
feels too similar to the one D&D are
producing now it will be set in the same
universe but it could potentially not
even take place in Westeros in the Seven
Kingdoms
chances are the new shame may be set in
Essos secondly George said he has worked
with and will continue to work with all
of the writers HBO has brought on to
create a new show or shows depending how
many get picked up after the pilots this
is great news for the television series
they are creating we need George
involved as much as possible so the
story stays on track and follows the
theme he's going for in his writing but
on the other hand that's bad news for
everyone waiting for one's a winner
the longer George spends time on a new
show leaves him with less time to finish
ones of winner so you're going to have
to take the good with the bad on that
one in another interesting detail George
gave us was that HBO hired a fifth
writer which is insane because HBO is
obviously fully committed to expanding
on this world and the television format
which makes me very happy because I want
this to go on forever if it's possible
but the best news about this fifth
writer they hired is what George said
about him George said other than him and
ilio and Linda he doesn't know anyone
else who knows and loves Westeros as
well as he does now that is very very
exciting because this is the type of man
we need on this project we don't just
want a fanboy of George's work we need
someone that actually knows the story
and the message George is trying to
relay in his story and what that being
said I hope this writer is locked in to
provide his services if George said this
guy knows his [ __ ] then I want him on
board especially if George can't always
be there perhaps this man or ilio and
Linda can be an extension of George to
ensure that the right story is being
told
on television and another thing we have
to keep in mind here which George
basically set himself just because HBO
hired five writers and they are working
on five different new shows doesn't mean
we are getting five new shows not all
pilots get picked up and if you know
their story about the Game of Thrones
original pilot then you know it was an
absolute disaster and damn near derailed
the show before it even got off the
ground but yes they are working on five
new shows but we do not know which if
any get picked up HBO could end up
firing all five of these writers and
hiring five new ones this stuff happens
all the time but given how successful
Game of Thrones has been for them you
can pretty much guarantee we are going
to get at least one new show and another
important thing to notice which shows we
will not be getting anytime soon we will
not get Dunkin egg nor Robert's
rebellion but George said Duncan egg
isn't completely out of the question yet
he said that he just wants to finish
flushing out the story more before he
jumps into it like he did what Game of
Thrones he does not want the television
show passing him by again before he can
even finish the story and the good news
about not getting Robert's rebellion is
George said when Thea Song of Ice and
Fire novels are finished we will have
all the remaining answers we need
pertaining to Robert rebellion which is
great news because I was hoping we
wouldn't be left with only vague
information about everything that
happened during that time period we will
be getting all those answers which is
we're leaving and last but certainly not
least George is still working on winds
of winter shocking right I think we all
knew that and I hope none of you are
expecting it anytime soon because I'm
afraid he is waiting to release it after
the entire Game of Thrones series has
ended I don't know why I feel that way
but for some reason I think he wants to
wait for the show to end before he puts
anything else out but that's just my
opinion but I think this will about do
it for today I hope this news was
exciting to you as it was for me I need
everybody to comment below and tell me
which new series do you want HBO to your
produce
would you like egg ons conquest would
you like the long night The Dance with
Dragons Blackfyre rebellion comment down
below and let's decide what's part of
the story would be best to explore some
more thanks for watching everyone I
really appreciate you stopping by and
spending some of your time with me also
I have to give a big thank you to
everyone supporting the channel over on
patreon I really appreciate all the love
some of you have given me
I can't thank you enough and if you are
a patreon supporter make sure you go
check out my last post over on patreon
because I will be doing a Q&A for you so
make sure you leave some questions for
me there thanks and I'll see you all
down in the comment section bye